climate is so important that
you know i'm dedicated to the cause
[Music]
it would be
critical for all these climate
technologies is to get the cost down
and to
be able to scale them up uh
to a pretty gigantic level you'll never
get that scale up
unless the government's coming in with
the right policies and
for the tough areas the right policy is
exactly what's in that infrastructure
bill what's great in this bill is this
has a
demonstration funding over 25 billion
until you do the demonstration project
you cannot get to a market driven price
and the goal of the demonstration
projects is
to drop the green premium over time all
the way to zero so that using clean
hydrogen eventually as part of how you
make steel for example that the market
alone makes that effective and so the
government and innovation play this
dramatic role not just for the us but
for the entire world
these big leaps forward to demonstrate
that we can actually do it so what this
shows this leadership shows is that the
private sector is hungry to partner is
hungry to get in the game on this and
we're hoping that this um example
sparks others to also step up and make
sure that we can get these demonstration
projects uh fully funded and in the
ground and going quickly it really helps
to you know grease the skids to make
sure it happens quickly because we are
in a moment of urgency
what happens if the bill doesn't get
passed there are still questions about
what the house is going to do
in that case do you walk away i would be
super disappointed if the bill
doesn't pass i will continue to share
that with politicians of both parties
but the
the focus for large demonstration
projects will be outside the united
states uh
much more in europe than asia
than in the united states which means
you don't get the direct connection with
the huge innovation power of the united
states
you don't get that early lead in these
industries which often determines where
the long-term
job creation is i'll keep
finding the ways to draw in
the u.s innovation